PAUL KINLAN: Hi.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
I work on Chrome, and
I've briefly worked
on the Web Lab project.
I'm here with two of the
engineers behind Web Lab, as
well, Roger and Mattias.
Do you want to give yourself a
little bit of an introduction?
ROGER PALA: I'm Roger.
I'm a creative technologist at
B-Reel, and I've been the
technical lead of the project.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL:
And I'm Mattias.
I am also a technical
creative.
Do you say that?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It's either a
creative technical or a
technical creative.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: I don't
know the difference.
PAUL KINLAN: [INAUDIBLE]
I'm an instrument technician not
a-- oh it doesn't matter.
I'm a technical supervisor not
a supervising technician.
Instrument technician,
that was my dad.
That's my dad's job.
Anyway, sorry.
So we're here to talk about the
Web Lab project Web Lab is
a series of five real-world
Chrome experiments inside the
British Science Museum
in London.
And over the series of a couple
of Hangouts, we've
basically been introducing
each of the experiments.
So today's is the Teleporter
experiment.
And the Teleporter
is really cool.
It's basically three
Teleporters, three periscopes
inside the museum, essentially,
which you can
move along or move
around and be
transported across the world.
I think we've got one in a shark
tank in South Africa.
So we've got a camera, a
360-degree camera, inside the
shark tank.
One in a miniature world in--
where is it?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Hamburg.
PAUL KINLAN: In Hamburg.
And then one in the bakery just
outside New York, I think.
Isn't it?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
A 24-hour bakery.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
a 24-hour bakery.
It's pretty cool.
The really cool thing I like
about this experiment--
obviously, it's very physical,
even though everything about
it is digital--
but when you get online you
still get this very similar
type of experience.
So just some of this--
I took my son to the British
Science Museum and we went on
[? the site to ?] play
with it, took
photos of where we were.
I mean, he had no idea where
the places were, but he was
like, this is so cool.
It's like they're working
in the bakery.
I said, yeah, they've
woken up.
It was 6 o'clock in the morning,
and it's guys in the
bakery just pounding dough
and everything.
It was pretty crazy.
But anyway, let's jump
into the experiment.
So this is the main screen
giving you an introduction
about what it looks like
inside the museum.
So these are the periscopes,
at least.
I have a little theme.
For every single Hangout
that we've done--
I told you about the loading
screens-- and this
was Flash as well.
Was it originally Flash
convergences?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: To a Swiffy.
PAUL KINLAN: To a Swiffy.
So it's all in HTML5
in JavaScript, but
via the Flash process.
I get that in every time.
It's something I learned just
from this past week.
It's pretty crazy.
So this is the actual Teleporter
project on the
website, which gives you pretty
much the exact same
experience that you get
at the museum, right?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: So we have
the three cameras.
We have this one here on the
left, which is the deli.
Hover over it.
That's a pretty cool transition,
wasn't it?
This is the miniature world in
Hamburg, and then this is the
rather dark, nighttime
aquatic museum in
South Africa, at least.
I think we'll just go with the
bakery one for most of this
with this Hangout.
It's got a lot of
stuff happening.
Oh, that was really cool.
Did you see that drop
off the screen then?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
This is just from other people,
they are taking.
PAUL KINLAN: Sorry, that's
the first time
I've ever seen that.
So basically what happens with
the Teleporter is that you can
take snapshots at the museum
or online as well, right?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And they get
recorded to your lab tag, so
when you go home you can get
them back and see what you
recorded and print it out.
So should we just jump on this
and have a brief technical
deep dive into what people are
seeing right now, and why
we've got donuts.
I mean, are these real donuts?
No, they're not real donuts,
but it's kind of crazy.
Should we start a different
way instead?
How can I say this?
There can be 10,000 people,
20,000 people at any one time
controlling these
cameras, right?
So should we jump into one?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Because
I want to show the
people what's happening.
So this is the actual museum.
This is the bakery just
outside New York.
Is it Amelie's Bakery?
ROGER PALA: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
And as we can see the camera
is moving around.
This is not the actual
camera moving is it?
ROGER PALA: No.
So we have a 360 camera on site,
and then it sends the
whole 360 panoramic view through
a WebM Live Streaming.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, it's
a WebM Live Stream.
ROGER PALA: Yeah, so we don't
use any plug-in for this
experiment.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So this is just literally the
video tag mapped on to--
I'm presuming this
is WebGL, is it?
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
So we receive this video
in the web of
an HTML video, basically.
It's like an infinite
HTML video.
And then we get this
data and we--
with a WebGL shader--
we transform it, and so--
PAUL KINLAN: So when you say
transform it, do you map it on
to the inside of a sphere
or something?
ROGER PALA: It's not actually a
sphere, it's just a fragment
shader that repositions each
of the pixels as--
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so it's
manipulating where the pixels
are to make it look like
it's kind of--
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: --or re-combine
this at [INAUDIBLE].
ROGER PALA: To get the
experience of the sphere.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
interesting.
I always thought you mapped
on to one texture.
You put on to the inside of a
sphere, then you move the
sphere around.
But it's even a little more
method than that.
You use a fragment shader.
See I was talking to
Paul Lewis the
other week about this.
I was calling them vertex--
I swear they were called
Vertex Shaders.
Maybe it's DirectX
or something.
And he's like, no, Paul, they're
fragment shaders.
He's like, huh.
That's how much I know
about know about web
[? geologists,?] generally.
So this is scrolling around, but
we do get the ability to
move around ourselves.
So we're not like a normal
webcam from the 1990s where
you would wait in the queue
for a minute and a half to
pass off, and then two seconds
later it would move up.
And you get complete control
of the webcam because it's
entirely virtual, right?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: The projection
onside the
screen is entirely virtual.
It's a 360-degree camera.
That's pretty cool.
So I wonder what they're
making now?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Brownies
or something.
They really look good.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, they
look really nice.
So if we wanted to, we could
take a snapshot, right?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Press the
space bar, it will
take a snapshot itself.
That's pretty cool.
So this kind of compass in the
background, I mean, is that
WebGL as well or--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: No,
that's actually SVG.
That's generated in real time,
so it's creating the tags as
you turn around.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh right, so it's
not even already pre-created.
It's like a big, long screen
that creates the individual
items and then positions
the text.
Oh wow, okay.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It's creating
all in real time.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
And how did you get this-- is
this bend effect here-- is
this part of the actual
fragment shader or--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: No.
The shader does much, but
just that effect, we
used the CSS mask.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, so you're
clipping off a region around
to give it.
That's pretty nice
stuff, isn't it?
Cool.
And I have a silly question.
This is going to sound
stupid, so excuse me,
everyone, if it is.
This halo effect,
is that just--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It's an SVG
overlaying the whole thing.
PAUL KINLAN: All right.
So it's like you have
it in a pastie?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And then you go
to transparent or opaque?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
We have someone looking
through the
window, and he's waving.
Hello.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: So this is how
we record these things.
It's pretty cool.
We go with the flow,
see how it goes.
So what were some of the
technical challenges that you
faced with this project?
ROGER PALA: So I would say that
the WebM Live Streaming
was quite challenging on the
back end, because, as far as
we know, it's the first time
that someone used this
technology.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I don't think we've ever made
any announcement or anything
that we actually are streaming
web and video over the--
we haven't.
[LAUGHTER]
PAUL KINLAN: It's
breaking news.
This might be cut out.
We don't know.
ROGER PALA: But obviously, like
with any new technology,
it's been quite challenging
to handle all the errors.
PAUL KINLAN: That's interesting
because, a lot of
the time that we've done
this, it's been a
YouTube Live Stream.
But I presume we couldn't
pipe the data--
the 360-degree camera data--
into YouTube.
ROGER PALA: No, it was not
possible to get the data live.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And I suppose the
interesting thing is--
actually, that is a really good
point-- is because that's
the benefit of the HTML video
stream is that you can,
literally, just put it into a
texture and map it, put it
through WebGL, which we--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROGER PALA: The performance
is much better.
If we were using Flash, we had
to send this data from Flash
to JavaScript, which was slowing
down a lot of the
whole process.
PAUL KINLAN: Wasn't there a very
early prototype where it
was a Flash-based?
ROGER PALA: Yeah, at the
beginning we were using Flash
and sending the image
data to the canvas.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm really glad
that you guys got this to
work, actually, because
it is beautiful.
The thing I like about this
project is you don't know
about any of the technology it
uses behind the scenes, right?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: You don't know it's
using WebGL, and SVG, and
Canvas, and all that type
of stuff to get this.
It just looks pretty cool.
I actually remember my son got
a picture of a shark swimming
past the front.
He thought it was brilliant.
He thought it was amazing.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And we have
seen people in the Miniatur
Wunderland getting engineers
coming up repairing stuff.
PAUL KINLAN: Really?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Kind of
reaching for the camera.
[LAUGHING]
PAUL KINLAN: Oh man,
that's pretty cool.
These are really cool,
these ones.
So just to jump onto this--
well, we have no screen,
so let me refresh.
Oh, it was loading.
ROGER PALA: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Did you see that?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It did say it was
loading just as I refreshed.
I love these things.
Actually, so we're gonna talk
about the Universal
Orchestra later on.
I love some of the animations
that you did in that one.
So if you get a chance to watch
the Universal Orchestra
Hangout, I would because
it's got some really
cool stuff in there.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And we seem
to have lost the internet.
PAUL KINLAN: No we haven't.
See, it's when you say we have
lost it, we get it back.
So this is a really
cool thing.
So I mean, you mentioned
something about canvas--
normal 2D canvas.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yes, so here
we have both the WebGL showing
the donut and which is actually
just one shader that
then transforms it into the
spherical view of it as well.
So that's one shader, and then
around it we have a 2D canvas
that shows the clock.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, so this clock
over on the outside here--
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
ROGER PALA: It is the timer.
PAUL KINLAN: This
is the timer.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: It's a pretty
nice layout.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And when you
roll over it, it's JavaScript
moving divs and stuff to
get that animation.
PAUL KINLAN: That's really
cool, isn't it?
You know, I still-- and I
said this earlier on--
I never saw the photos just
drop off last time.
Is that a relatively new thing,
or has that been there?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: It's
been there-- been
there from the start.
PAUL KINLAN: Seriously?
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: All right.
Can I click on them?
ROGER PALA: No.
PAUL KINLAN: Feature request.
[LAUGHING]
PAUL KINLAN: So that's
pretty cool, man.
Of course the live stream.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: And this is
from the museum, which is
closed at the moment.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty cool.
We probably have to get special
dispensation to get
people through this.
But this is at the
museum, right?
So these are the-- like you
can see on the right-- the
orange Teleporter and
the blue one there.
It's exactly the same type of
experience, right, where you
can take a photo, save it to
your laptop, and then get it
back later.
MATTIAS EKENDAHL: Yeah.
ROGER PALA: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: That's
pretty nice.
Yeah, so that was a nice little
deep dive into some of
the bits behind the Teleporter
project.
It's one of my favorite ones.
It's probably one of the most
interactive ones there, like
the physically interactive ones
at the museum itself.
If you get a chance, go and
check it out in the museum.
If not, check it out online.
It's just as good of a--
I can't speak.
It's an awesome experience.
Cool, thank you.